police States when they are under
construction when you're building them
you need a lot of subterfuge you need a
lot of Flim Flam you need a lot of smoke
and mirrors you need a lot of lying now
when you got a full-fledged police state
you don't need any lying you just walk
into a train station grab a guy you
don't give him any reasons you beat him
over the head he'll never be seen from
again but while you're building the
police state you need to fool people and
so you that's that's what's going on and
so we I think that our distrust of these
institutions is completely Justified I I
wonder if we're seeing a shift and I I
uh someone super chatted that uh you
know even Dave pornoy was supporting
Niki Haley and so I I just looked and I
see Dave poroy supporting Nikki Haley
yeah and the statement was Nikki Haley
saying something like um when Israel
moves into GA invades Gaza people are
going to call for restraint but Hamas
showed no restraint when they invaded
Israel and Dave's like I like Nicki more
and more